[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم مساء الخير معال
الدكتور مساء النور ربنا يخليك حضرتك
مشرفنا بهذه الحلقات الجميله تسلم ربنا
يخليك انا عندي سؤال بيلوح علي مش بس
بمناسبه هذه الحلقات اللي انا بستمتع فيها
الاستماع لحضرتك ولكن من
زمان وهي فكره لماذا اخترت ان تكون يساريا
يعني طب انا بطرحها ليه دلوقتي بغض النظر
عن فضولي القديم هو انه في الحلقات
السابقه انت دايما مركز على فكره العداله
الاجتماعيه واذكر انا حضرك يمكن لا تذكر
لما بسالك مره يعني اديني ابسط تعريف لما
هو اليسار في من وجهه نظرك قلت لي يعني
العداله الاجتماعيه انت مشغول جدا بفكر
فكره العداله الاجتماعيه وانا عندي 100000
سؤال لكن عاوز الاول
ابدا يعني كيف تسلل اليسار الى حياتك
وازاي انت اخترت ان تكون يساريا بس بعد ما
تعرف المشاهدين ابسط تعريف لليسار تمام هو
طبعا الاصل التاريخي لكلمه اليسار
واليساري واليساري واليساريين
ا الثوره الفرنسيه اه مظبوط وفي نمط
الجلوس في الجمعيه الوطنيه كما هي مجلس
الشعب عندنا ان كان المعارضين للنظام
والمطالبين بالتغيير والساعين اليه والذين
ضحوا في سبيله جلسوا الى اليسار الى
اليسار تمام وبالتالي من هنا اصبح تقليديا
تعبير اليسار يرمز ويدل على كل من يسعى
الى التغيير الوضع القائم الى وضع افضل
منه ده في المجمل لكن لما نحدد الكلام
بنتكلم نغير الوضع القائم اللي هو يعمل
لصالح القله الى وضع يعمل ونظام يعمل
لصالح المجموع او الاغلبيه ادي في تفريعات
كتير ده موضوع
اليسار بعض الناس بتقلق يعني مثلا بتكلم
من تجربه الشخصيه تلام زيت في الجامعه
يقول بنحبك جدا
ولكن حضرتك راجل يساري اقول لي يا ابني
يعني انت بالضبط ايه القصه يعني انا
ا يعني دي نقطه اعتقد دي مناسبه ان نتكلم
فيها ما علق في اذهان
الناس
بخصوص العلاقه بين اليسار والدين والدين
اه والدين كثير من الناس حتى يومنا هذا
يتصوروا ان انا ملحد والعياذ بالله وكثير
جدا اللي يتصوروا ان انا ماليش علاقه
بالطقوس
الدينيه انا اندهش جدا وهذكر وقعه يعني
لانها لا تخلو مندي لان كان عندي واحد من
تلميزات مسجل معايا دكتوراه وقعد بيشتغل
معايا ست اشهر كويس وبعدين بعد ست اشهر
جالي عشان اناقشه في ما كتبه وزارني في
البيت وكان الكلام ده مساء وادان العيشه
جه فانا بقول له يا فلان انت متوضي نصلي
ولا قال لي انا م طب تعال ايه
نصلي وقفت قيته وصلينا بعد ما صلينا لقيت
انه في حاله لخبطه عارف يعني مش هو وهو
كان صادق يعني قال لي دكتور انا معلش عايز
اصرحك بحاجه قلتله قاللي انا كنت لغايه
اللحظه دي فاكر ان حضرتك مالكش دعوه بال
مالكش علاقه الواطيه عن اليسار اي ده انا
قلت له يعني طلقا قلت لي يا ابني انا اللي
احب اضرب زبيبه ولا اشيل
سبحه ولا حتى اعمل القوس دي بحيث الناس
تشوفها لان ده يبقى اسمه رء الناس وان
رئاء الناس ده منهي عنه بكل النصوص
الصريحه
ضمنيه انما عايز الناس يعرفوا ان انا
الراجل بؤدي
كل الواجبات
الدينيه من صلاه ولا تعارض وصوم وزكاه خلي
بالك وزكاه زي الضرايب كمان مش يقوللك د
دي خلاص وطبعا قضيه فريضه الحج والعمره
وده طبعا بالنسبه للناس ايه ده انما انا
شايف في الواقع انه الدين الاسلامي
والديانات السماويه وبعض الديانات غير
السماويه عموما جوهرها واحد فكره الانشغال
بالانسان البسيط
والمقهور في اطار من العداله الاجتماعيه
ده وجهه نظري في الموضوع ولكن انا احب
دايما يبقى في مسافه مسافه كبيره وواضحه
بين الدين وبين الايه بين السياسه ده حول
موضوع ازاي انا بقيت يا سعري كويس ده سؤال
كان طرحته عل هو ده السؤال الاولاني قبل
ما اجي للاسئله الاخرى يعني اه طبعا هنا
النشاه مهمه جدا منتصف في لا في
الاربعينات من الق فكره التخرج بتتكلم على
لا قبل كده لانه في انا تلاد سنه 1942
يعني يعني معناها تجاوز 80 دلوقتي انيه
مظبوط وكاتب كده
في حكايه مصريه سنوات النشاه ازاي اثرت
نشات الاسره من المزارعين المصريين في
دلتا النيل واسره لم تكن معدمه ولكن فقيره
بمعنى انه ارضها لم تكن تكفي لاعت فبش
اجروا ارض تانيه يشتغلوا بانشطه اخرى
وبتاع ف انا
تفتحت تفتحت عيني وادراكي على هذا الواقع
انه في ترتبيه اجتماعيه بكل ما ترتبيه
يعني درجات
فئات في الباشا والبيه وفي الكذا وكل
الكلام ده
زائد في في مرحله
التكوين انا اصلا كنت بقعد لدخول الازهر
والمشروع فشل ماعرفش يير ليه حصل مواجهه
شديده بيني وعاصفه بيني وبين سيدنا اللي
كان بيحفظ مني القران وكان
قريبي وحسيت انه يعني بدل ما هو ينورني
ويفهمني بيقهر مني بساله في سوره
القلم عن معنى سن سموه على الخرطوم وانا
كل محفظه انساها زي كثير من الاطفال زي
كثير من الاطفال فبقوله ببراءه يعني فهمها
لي عشان ايه يعني تدخل ما تخرجش ق لا انت
تحفظ ورجلك في ور واجه الخطوره بقى انك
يعني ما
تناقش ابتدى يعني وقع بعد وقع ابتدت تكرس
لدي الاحساس بانه
الواقع
ظالم وينبغي ان نكافح في سبيل تعديله الا
هو اليسار من بدء من اول سنسمه على مزبوط
فتدل المسار الى اليسار البذره الاولى
وطبعا تكرست في سنوات عبد الص مبط طيب انا
الحقيقه كان الكلام كله في ذهني على
اليسار بس انا لفت نظري حاجه ربما يجرف
الحديث وهو اصلا برض كان سؤال مؤجل بس قبل
ما اسال حضرتك السؤال المؤجل واذكر
اصدقائنا الدكتور جوده اعطى اجابه سريعه
وسوف اعود الى اليسار مره ثانيه و وعلى ال
كيف يعني السلطات اللي نجحت او فشلت
بممارسه اليسار لكن اللي عاوز يعرف يسار
احنا عندنا حلقه تحدثنا فيها بالتفصيل عن
التعريفات اليسار واليمين والنشاه
التاريخيه وسوف اضع لكم رابطها مع الدكتور
قبل ما اتكلم على اليسار والحديث عنه
موصول يعني انت حضرتك اكلمت في بشكل
تلقائي على الدين وانه بتعتقد ان جوهر
الدين هو الاهتمام بالانسان البسيط
وبالتالي العداله الاجتماعيه
يعني ما يعني ان انت بتشوف ان ما فيش
تعارض بين اليسار وبين الدين طب ما هو ده
بياخدنا لسؤال شاغل ناس كتيره قوي يقول لك
طيب يعني ما العيب او لماذا تنتقد انتم
كمفكر وفلاسفه شعار الاسلام هو الحل ما
الجماعات الاسلاميه متعدده ومنهم الجماعه
الاكبر طبعا جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
ابتدعت شعار الاسلام هو الحل ففيما تع ض
يعني تمام هنا عايز ابدا بنقطه مهمه يا
سيد الساده المشاهدين
انه اعود الى مقوله للسلف الصالح الحكم في
الشيء فرع من تصوره كويس طيب انما نناقش
بقى شعار الاسلام
والحل السؤال الاول تطبيقا لمقوله الحكم
في الشيء هو ماذا نقصد
بالاسلام وماذا نقصد بالحل
عظيم بالنسبه للسؤال الاول الاسلام طبعا
لمن
يقرع
تطور النظم الاسلاميه منذ بدايه
الاسلام حتى يومنا هذا حجد تنوعات شديده
جدا ود اجتهادات كثيره جدا
وهناك
اولا مذهب شيعي ومذهب سني و هناك مذاهب
سنيه وهب
شيعيه مبوط وبالتالي ده يطرح سؤال اسلام
من علاج التحديد سيدنا محمد على سبيل
المثال عليه الصلاه والسلام يعني كتب فيه
شاعر احمد
شوبيك الاشتراكيون انت امامهم لولا دعاوى
القوم واعتقد انه هذا الكلام لم ياتي من
فراغ لانه لو نظرت الى صلب
الدعوه هتجد انه هي
كده الرق والعبوديه تحرير
الرقبه الصدقه
الزكاه انحيازه دائما حتى انه يعني لما
ادار ظهره
لده جاي في النص القران عبث وتولى
مظبوط يعني احد المكفوفين ليمه على هذا مش
كده ايه نص القران فده كله معناه ايه انه
لابد ان ننظر الى الاسلام من منظور تاريخي
جز منه طبعا رساله سماويه جت ده مؤكد ولكن
هذه الرساله السماويه
ا تتعامل مع واقع اولا تاريخيا متغير
ثانيا جغرافيا
مختلف فلما تجي تتكلم على الاسلام في
افريقيا غير لما تتكلم على الاسلام في
اسيا الوسطى على سبيل المثال او الاسلام
في مصر او الاسلام في الجزيره العربيه حيث
نشا الناس بتتصور انه ا يقول لك تسعه اشار
رزق في التجاره وده حديث عن الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام حديث
صحيح انما دي مقوله لابد ان تفهم في
السياق التاريخي بمعنى انها قيلت من حوالي
15 قرن ده تاريخيا وقيلت في مكان معين
جغرافيا اللي هو الجزيره العربيه الجزيره
العربيه حيث في الواقع الموارد هي ايه
رحلات الشتاء والصيف القوافل
ها تتجه جنوبا تجيب بضاعه تمر بمكه وبعدين
تتجه شمالا الى الشام وذا هو المنوال
الاقتصادي طبعا 19س رزق في التجاره لكن من
في راينا من الخطا ان نسقط هذا الفهم على
اللحظه الحاليه ونقول 19 رزق في التجاره
وبالتالي الراجل نشاط تجاري وبتاع لانه
هذا في في فهم خاطئ فدي اول نقطه انه
النظر الى
الاسلام من منظور تاريخي والمنظور
التاريخي يعني ببساطه ان الخطا ان ننظر له
ولا يجب ان ننظر له من يجب انا قلت كده في
سياقه يعني مظبوط لابد ان ننظر الى
الاسلام بمنظور تاريخي والمنظور التاريخي
يعني النسبيه اه ان ما كان مناسب في وقت
من الاوقات ربما لم يعد بالضبط كده ولذلك
مثلا يعني روي عن الرسول عليه ال والسلام
انه اهل مكه ادر بشعبها ده معناها انه
تاكيد لفكره التنوع مكانيا و متصل بفكره
تنوع زمليه خلاص فاذا ده تقديم في شكل
الطريقه الانسب في رايي لطرح هذه المقوله
اللي هي الاسلام هو الايه هو
الحل ججي طبعا للقران وهو النص الاعلى
والاسمى وياتي بعد الحديث
والسنه
الاسلام بعض
نصوصه لا تفهم الا في سياق التاريخي اللي
هو ما يسميه العلماء علماء القران اسباب
النزول الايه دي في واقعه معينه استدعت
هذه الايه هذه
الايه يبقى انا هزم نفسي بالقيم العليا
والمبادئ الاساسيه
للقران اما المسائل اللي هي ظهرت في
سياقات معينه فانا اتعامل معها من هذا لا
انكرها ولكن هفهمها في هذا السياق التاريخ
انا ممكن اسال حضرتك السؤال بطريقه ايسر
شويه وقطع النظر عن القناعات الخاصه
الدينيه الخاصه بحضرتك او باخرين انت
كعالم اقتصاد هل يوجد ما يسمى وعندك تجربه
كبيره
هل يوجد ما يسمى بالاقتصاد الاسلامي لا لا
لا دي خرافه الاقتصاد الاسلامي خرافه
بدعه بمعنى
ايه انه الاقتصاد علم طبعا هناك
مجال لاعمال التاريخ بمعنى مع التطور
بتتطور الاوضاع وبالتالي تتطور القوانين
المفسره لهذه الايه الاوضاع فنتكلم في
الاقتصاد ان نقحم تعبير الاقتصاد الاسلامي
ينطوي على خطوره شديده بمعنى ايه ان يجمد
الاقتصاد في قالب معين مستمد من النصوص مع
اهمال الاصل التاريخي لبعض هذه
النصوص وايضا يفتح المجال لانه يجي
المسيحي
يقوللك الاقتصاد المسيحي واليهودي يقوللك
الاقتصاد اليهودي الى
اخ كده يحدث اضطراب شديد انت بتتكلم على
ظاهره مجتمعيه تحتاج الى اعمال قواعد
العلم والمنطق في دراستها
واستخلاص المبادئ الحاكمه لها وفي هذا
المعنى يستوي المسيحي مع الاسلامي مع
اليهودي واحد اثنين برد عشان الناس تبقى
معانا انه انا ممكن اتكلم عن نظام اقتصادي
اسلامي وليس اقتصاد اسلامي نقطه مهمه جدا
جدا نظام اقتصادي اسلامي ما معنى نظام
الاقتصادي الاسلامي لو النظام اللي الممكن
لو ترجع بقى في سياق التاريخ الاسلامي ها
ترجع لايام عمر بن الخطاب وعمر بن عبد
العزيز والكلام ده كله وتشوف معنى نظام
اقتصادي اسلامي قائم اساسا على العداله
الاجتماعيه وجزء منه حمايه كت العاجز عن
الاسباب خارج ارادته عن انه يكفل نفسه
المجتمع بيكفل دي الحمايه انما العداله
معناه انك انت يعني تكون ل حد ما سواسيه
يبين الناس في الفرص في الفرص
والامكانيات اذا نميز بين نظام الاقتصادي
الاسلامي وده انا يعني اتحمس له
كثيرا اما الاقتصاد الاسلامي كعلم فلا
اتحمس له واعتقد انها مغالطه كبرى من
النوادر جدا انج ان بعض اساس الجامعه انا
بتكلم على مصر ماعرفش الدول الثانيه يمكن
لو حد من المشاهدين عنده تجارب
يقول يطلع الكتاب بيميه الاحصا الاسلامي
كويس كده وبعدين تيجي تشوف ايه الاحصا
الاسلامي دي تجد ان هو بيدي امثله على
حساب المتوسط يجيب لك عدد اعداد الحجيج
على مدى 30 سنه و في حد قال احصاء اسلامي
اه في كتب بهذا العنوان لانها اصبحت سبوبه
يعني مجال
للتكسب ولذلك انا بحذر من هذه النزعه جدا
اقتصاد اسلامي لا لانه لا معنى له ترجمه
على الارض لو انا جهت الموضوع ده حينما
عملت
وزيرا اكتشفت ان طبعا عملت وزير في مرحله
كان فيها الاخوان في الحكم قمه تالقهم و
عندهم تشريع ورئيس في نفس الوقت انما
بالنسبه لهم الاسلام يترجم بقى هو الحل
يترجم ايه تسعه اشار رزق في
التجاره فقط وهنا بقى خطوره انك انت
تقتلع نصوص من السياقه التاريخيه زي ت رزق
في التجاره وانه الذكاء ويس الكلام ده انت
بتتكلم على مرحله تجاوزاتها البشريه في كل
مكان في العالم
فاذا نظام اقتصادي معناها ان
استوحي القيم الاسلاميه
العليا في الرحمه وفي الزهد ايضا عايز
اقول تقشف وانا عايز اقول انه في الواقع
لما بتراقب مثلا بعض الجماعات الاسلاميه
ما يعرفوش حاجه اسمها زهب يعني عايز
يستهلك حتى نخاع ويشرب حتى الثماله وليكن
ما يكون فده في رايي نظر جزئيه جدا انت
عايز الرحمه
والزهد وايضا الحرص على عماره الارض وهنا
نيجي بقى للبيئه والتغير المناخي وكل
الايه وكل الكلام ده
والانتاج في مواجهه التجاره في مجتمع زي
المجتمع مصري ا بكل ما يعنيه واساسا قائم
على رافض رئيسي هو نهر النيل لا يمكن تقول
لتجاره وذلك انا اندهش حاليا من بعض
الدعوات التتي انطلقت
مؤخرا في شكل
مستهدفات وطنيه تحويل مصر الى مركز
لوجيستي لوجيستي يعني مركز تجاره حد بضاعه
خزنه و طب انت فين الانتاج في هذا الموضوع
اذا كانت جنب يعني مراكز انتاج اخرى لا بس
لا انا بقوله فاقد الشيء اللي يعطيه لك
انت لكي يوجد لديك نشاط بهذه الطبيعه اللي
هو النشاط لوجستي لابد ان يكون لديك قاعده
انتاجيه يرتكز عليه هذا هو الوضع في كل
بلاد العالم بما في ذلك مناطق زي دبي وجبل
علي مثلا
وبين سين غفوره كان نماذج يعني بيشار اليه
في هذا الجاع
فمقولة ش اقول بعضها عشان ماعملش احكام
مسبقه انت حضرتك عايشت بعض هذه التجارب
منها مثلا تجربه السودان وهو عاده لما
بيتكلموا على الاقتصاد الاسلامي لسبب ما
بيذهب الى البنوك مضبوط اه هو يمكن اختصار
النظام اقتصادي في البنوك لا لا يمكن ولكن
بحكم ان البنوك يعني هي من
الانشطه اللي يمكن اكثر من غيرها يمكن
اخضاعها
لسلطه الدوله في النهايه فبتحب خاصه زائد
وضعيتها في السياق الاقتصادي بشكل عام لكن
بهذه المناسبه عايز اقول انا يعني ك خلفيه
للكلام ومن منظور المسلم الملتزم وليس
مجرد الخبير
الاقتصادي طلب
مني من حيقه الامم المتحده اجراء دراسه عن
السياسات
اقتصاديه لمكافحه الفقر في السودان كويس
ده كان سنه كام دكتور الكلام ده كان في
سنه
2000 2000 تقريبا 2000 2001 يعني من حوالي
22 سنه مضبوط و انا رئيس فريق شكلت فريق
كبير من حوالي 15
خبير عدد كبير منهم حرصت ان يكون خبراء
سودانيين وعدد اخر خبراء من دول الجداره
والكفاءه اللي هم من دول مختلفه وكان
الموضوع اجابه على سؤال ما هي السياسات
الاقتصاديه الكليه اللازمه ل تقليل الفقر
في في سودان ف نمره واحد لازم ت تحدد حجم
مشكله الفقر في السودان واحد اثنين اين
تتمركز هذه المشكله هل هي في الريف ولا في
الحضر او في الاثنين الى اخره ثلاثه شوف
كيف
يعني تتخذ وتستخدم تدابير للتعامل مع
الوقت ده كان في وقت كان في النظام
السياسي والاقتصادي في السودان قائم على
يسمى تطبيق مبادئ الشريعه الاسلاميه
وترجمه لهذا ترجمه لهذا قال لك انه تم
تعديل نظام البنوك في السودان بعيدا عنما
يسمى بيوت الربا كما يطلق خون عل الى ا
بيوت ماليه
اسلاميه فنتج عن ذلك اولا ا تقريبا الغاء
دور البنك المركزي
السوداني اثنين انه
ا لا يوجد حاجه اسمها معاملات
بالفايده باعتبار ان المعاملات الفايده
عباره عن ربا وان الفايده ربا وال والربا
منهي عنه بنص صريح في القران
الكريم هناك صيغ اخرى اسلاميه للمعاملات
الماليه ا تتحاشى استخدام
الفائده من هذه باعتبار ان الاقتصاد
السوداني اقتصاد زراعي كان في حاجه اسمها
ال نظام سلمه ونظام الى اخره التفاصيل
اوكي كلها صيغ بتحاول تقوم على فكره تجنب
الربع مظبوط انا بس عايز اتوقف عند موضوع
ربا لان في لغط كتير جدا وعاز الشير
لواقعه لطيفه جدا ان في وقت من الاوقات
كان عندنا في مصر اهم مرجعين دينيين اللي
هو شيخ الازهر ومفتي
الديار كل منه كان له راي مختلف في موضوع
فوائد البنوك اذكر تماما انا اذكر سالك
ايض مظبوط على وجه التحديد صحح ني ان
خانتني الذاكره انه شيخ الازهر
ا كان رايه
انه فوائد ال بنوك ربا اظن كان من غير ذكر
اسامي خلاص بينما مفت الديار في ذلك الحين
افتى بانه فوائد يعني اوكي الدكتور سيد
طنطاوي افتى بان فوائد ال البنوك ليست
ربا والشيخ جاد الحق علي جاد الحق افتى
بان فؤد بنك ربا ودول اهم مرجعين دينيين
انجاز التعبير فهنا بيز انتهز هذه الفرصه
وصحح مفهوم في الواقع اللي هو مفهوم الربا
اعود الى ما ذكرته وهو
اهميه ان نظر الى الموضوع من منظور
تاريخي من منظور تاريخي حينما نعود
الى بدء ظهور الاسلام والنص القراني اللي
بيقول احل
الله با وحرم الربا مظبوط مش ده النص في
ذلك الحين كانت نقود اما من ذهب اللي هو
الدينار والدرهم والفضه عظيم ودي في مفهوم
الاقتصاديين نسميها نقود تمه القيمه اللي
هي المصنوعه من معادن نفيس بمعنى انه مع
مرور الوقت بترتفع
اسعار المعادن دي وبالتالي ترتفع القيمه
بتاعتها ده غير النقود الورقيه فانا ل جيت
سيد لو استلفت منك 100 جنيه الهب النهارده
رجعهم لك بعد سنه انا ممكن يمكن اخد منك
فايده ليه لانه لما ارجعلك انا جديده بعد
سنه غالبا تكون قيمه الذهب علقل ما خسرتش
يعني انا ما خسرتش تمام فده كان وبالتالي
مفهوم جدا ان لما واحد يستلف 100 دينار او
درهم او يسلف مش المفروض انه يطلب زياده
ادي معنى الربا انما حاليا في في زمن
النقود
الورقيه الامر ليس كذلك بمعنى ان النقود
تفخد جزء من قيمتها بمرور الوقت على خلفيه
ارتفاع الاسعار وبالتالي يحوم انت تطلب
مظبوط مظبوط كده ده في الواقع تاكيد لفكره
العداله بين الايه بين الاطراف نيجي بقى
في السودان عمل ايه وبالمناسبه للمهتم لحس
ناس بتتابع وبتسال اسئله انا كتبت فصل في
الكتاب كنت بدرسه في الجامع نقود البنوك
عن تحت عنوان كده البنوك الاسلاميه او
البنوك في الاسلام فمحتاج محتاج تفاصيل
اكثر يرجع انما بالنسبه للسد لفه نظري انه
هذه السياسه اللي المفروض يبقى ظاهرها
وباطنه الرحمه كان ظاهره الرحمه وباطنه
العذاب بمعنى انه نتيجه لتطبيق عدد من
الصياغه المسماه اسلاميه في معاملات معينه
زي مثلا تقديم تمويل
للفلاحين كويس
ا انه مع تحرك اسعار المحاصيل من ت الثاني
ومع تعرض الزراعات لظروف طبيعيه غير
مواتيه زي مثلا افات وما شابه بت تضطرب
الاوضاع ونتج عن هذا
دخل الملايين من الفلاحين السودانيين
الفقراء
السجن على خلفيه هذا الموضوع وده موضوع
موثق جدا وثق ايوه موثق يعني المرحله دي
والتقرير موجود
ونشر هذا الاسم باللغه الانجليزيه سنه
2003 السياسات الكليه لمكافحه الفقر في في
السودان انما انا برضو لتحاشي
الحساسيات كنت حريص على انه واحد
من الخبراء الرئيسيين استاذ سوداني استاذ
اقتصاد كبير وفي نفس الوقت له خلفيه
اسلاميه ولكن ليست الخلفيه
الاسلاميه اللي هي الاخرى المروجه لفكره
تس عش رزق في التجاره والاسلام هو الحل
كان بيظر الى الموضوع نظره يعني رحبه
وموضوعيه و يعني حسبنا بقى
حسبنا لما تعمل معاملات طبقا للصيغه
المسماه اسلاميه مثلا من صيغه المرابحه
انت مثلا عايز قرض من البنك عشان تشتري
سياره يقول لك لا انا مش هديك قرض لانه
القرض ده فيه فايده وكلام مش م اسلاميه
نعمل ايه عملل معاك عقد مرابحه انت قولي
بقى مواصفات السياره عايز ايه بالضبط فيها
الماركه والسنه وال وانا هستورد السياره
كيس كده
وهحلم تكلفه
معاملات وتسد الاص بدي الفاده وانا خلال
الفتره دي كل انا مالك السياره انت مالكش
دعوه للبنك او المؤسسه وعشان اختبر الكلام
ده انا كنت في وقت وقات خبير في البنك
الدولي في الكويت ورحت قلت البنك انا عايز
اجيب سياره قال لي حاضر تك تك تك تك تك
طلع انه ورحت البنك الثاني من اللي هو مش
اسلامي طلع انه في فرق انه تدفع الضعف
طبقا لصيغه ال ما يسمى المعاملات
الاسلاميه بالمقارنه بالمعاملات ال اذا
الموضوع كله شكلي وينطوي على فهم خاطئ
وتفسير خاطئ للنصوص الا الدينيه ورؤيه غير
تاريخيه الى الايه الى الامور هل تسمحي لي
ازيدك بمثال يعني انا هنا عايشت في مصر بس
مش اقدر اقول المؤسسات او يعني ولكن انا
كنت بنتمي لمؤسسه كبيره بشتغل فيها ووفرت
لنا فرص الحصول على قروض من بنك اسلامي
اوكي ذهبت وطلبت القرض لا اذكر يعني الغرض
منه وقتها فلقيته جايب لي عقد
شراء اقماح وشعير وكذا فقلت انا عارف بس
انا حبيت ان انا وجدت الموظف كده شكله غر
كده ممكن اخد منه معلومات فقلت له بس انا
مش جاي اشتري منكم قمح ولا اعير قاللي ما
انا عارف بس انت دي احنا احنا بنك اسلامي
ما اقدرش اقول لك هديلك قرض لكن انت انت
هتوكل ني اشتري لك الحاجات ديت في مقابل
نسبه ارباح ونسبه الارباح ديت هي ك وكان
الراجل ساذج الى حد يعني ممكن يضيع البنك
لكن ده اللي حصل فلكن طبعا انا احنا
بنتكلم على بعض البنوك جايز بعض بنوك اخرى
بتبذل جهد حتى وان لم تكن موفقه بس انا
عندي سؤال اعام يا معالي الدكتور تفضل اذا
كان لي اجابه بسيطه ما كانش ممكن نخليه في
حلقه ثانيه يعني هو علميا احنا ما نعرفش
غير نظامين بتفريع النظام الراس مالي
بتفريع الكثيره جدا او النظام الاخر بقى
نسميه الظام يساري نسميه شيوعي بتفريع
المختلفه ودرجاته لما اقول نظام اقتصادي
ده ليه مثلا تعريف علمي انه مثلا بيعالج
امور معينه ادوات الانتاج مثلا فائض
الانتاج يعني ليه تعريف معين اه له تعريف
طبعا ما هو التعريف تعريف النظام
الاقتصادي ايه النظام الاقتصادي هو
ا مجموعه
القواعد كويس كده ا التي تحدد من يملك
وسائل
الانتاج وكيف يتم اتخاذ القرارات بالنسبه
للانتاج ما ينتج وما لا ينتج وتوزيع عادي
انتاج على المشاركين في العمليه الانتاجيه
ادي النظام الاقتصادي هل تدينا مثال عشان
يبقى كده ادي مثال لما نيجي مثلا امريكا
كنظام راس مالي بالنسبه للسؤال الاول من
الذي يملك وسائل الانتاج الافراد اساسا
وسائل الانتاج يعني المصانع
والادوات يعني المصانع والمزارع وكل
الكلام دوت لا تملك الدوله لا يعني بشكل
عام واستثناء تملكوا الدوله استثناء تمام
طيب على اي اساس تتخذ القرارات على
اساس والطوق مظبوط الطلب والسوق كيف يتم
توزيع الانتاج طبقا لتفاعلات العرض والطلب
في السوق ايضا التي تحدد العائد الذي يحصل
عليه من ينتج هذه السلع ومن ينتج هذه
السلع
عظيم الدوله بيبقى لها دور مع الحكومه في
هذه الحاله ومؤسستها وهو دور ضابط الايقاع
عندك فرقه موسيقيه ومايسترو بيضبط الامور
عشان النغمه تطلع ورغم ذلك تاريخيا وجد ان
النظام الاقتصادي
الراسمالي به عيوب
جسيمه ينتج عنها امرين الامر الاول هو
نزعه
مركزيه لتردي العداله الاجتماعيه وغياب
العداله الاجتماعيه وده ينتج عن اضطرابات
سياسيه حصل اكثر مره الامر الثاني هو
الازمات النظام تنفجر فيه الازمات من
داخله من داخله وليس من
خارجه بيحقق درجه عاليه من الكفاءه
الاقتصاديه بالمعنى المباشر بمعنى انه انا
كمنتج بحصل على اعلى مردود من الموارد
التي استخدمها انما هل المجتمع ككل بيحصل
على اعلى مردود على الموارد ده سؤال مطروح
ومفتوح ويستحق مناقشه ولكن في الجانب
الثاني بقى النظام الثاني اللي هو النظام
الاخر اللي هو النظام الاشتراكي خلينا
نسميه ب مسمياته بقى ا هو انه ملكيه عامه
لوسائل الانتاج ان الدوله بتلعب دول كبير
او عندها حصه كبيره من وسائل الانتاج مبوط
عندنا صيغه القطاع العام وما شابه العظيم
اثنين ان القرارات الخاصه بالانتاج تتخذ
بناء على خطه هي التي تحدد ما ينتج وما لا
ينتج والكميات والانواع والكلام ده كله
ثلاثه التوزيع التوزيع يتم اعمالا لمبدا
العداله
الاجتماعيه طيب قبل يعني طبعا ممكن نرجئ
ايهما يعني كان اكثر نجاحا وفشلا بس هنا
دول ده تعريف النظام عشان النظام يبقى
نظام لازم يكون ليه موقف واضح من ادوات
الانتاج اي مضبوط و ملكيه ادوات الانتاج
ملكيه ادوات الانتاج واساس اتخاذ قرارات
الانتاج واساس اتخاذ قرارات الانتاج
والحاجه الثالثه اللي هي فائد الانتاج بقى
يعني العائد هيروح لمين صحيح هل في في
الاسلام يعني فيما يسمى الاقتصاد الاسلامي
في اي موقف واضح بين العوامل الثلاثه دول
القاعده
العامه كما كما افهم واعلم اللي هو ملكيه
ادوات الانتاج تبقى ملكيه خاصه بالدرجه
الاولى وملكيه الدوله في اضق الحدود عظيم
ا ما ينتج وما لا ينتج القرارات الخاصه
بها لا تتم بناء على خطه انما تتم بناء
على تفاعلات السوق من عرض وطلب التوزيع
بيتم طبقا لما يتمخض
عنه مقابله العرض والطلب في بالنسبه نظام
الراس هو اقرب لنظام الرس ب التفاصيل ا
ولكن اتفضل اذا كنا نتكلم عن نظام اسلامي
بقى هنا هنا المنطلق بتاعه والحرص
باستمرار الالتزام بالقيم الاسلاميه
العليا من منظور اسلامي الخمر كنشاط
اقتصادي غير مرحب به عظيم وبالتالي
في سياق النظام الاقتصادي الاسلامي كل ما
يتعلق بهذا النشاط انتاجا واستهلاكا لا
يحظى لا بالتشجيع ولا بالتيسير ولا باي
حاجه مثلا يعني تبقى فروق ثقافيه ما
الهندوس عندهم عادات ايوه
مظبوط المختلفه يعني عندهم عادات مظبوط
عشان كده بقول اهميه النظره التاريخيه
للامور تاريخيه بالمعنى الواسع تاخد
الجغرافيا والتاريخ مع بعض انه مايا صح في
نطاق جغرافي معين قد لا يكون كذلك يعني
مثلا اتكلم على الناس اللي ماشيين في
افريقيا يقول لك عراه هو الجو كده مش
معناه انه ابيح يعني لا هو الجو كده ومن
الخطا ان انا انظر نظره دونيه ولذلك تجد
انه الممارسات الاسلاميه في المجتمعات
الافريقيه مختلفه من وجوه كثيره اختلافات
مهمه جدا على
الممارسات الاسلاميه في وادي النيل عندنا
او في الجزيره او في مكان تاني انا اذكر
انه زميل حضرتك واستاذك رحمه الله دكتور
محمد ويدر ايوه كان قال ملحوظه مش عارف
اذا كان حضرتك تشاركوا الراي فيها ولكن
اذكر انه كان قال لي ان الاسلام لم يبتدع
قواعد خاصه به فيما يتعلق باداره النشاط
الاقتصادي في البلاد التي دخلها واحني الى
مجموعه كتب منها كتب ابن عبد الحكم في
التاريخ وقال مثلا لما دخلوا مصر هل
النشاط الاقتصادي في مصر تغير قبل دخول
عمرو بن العاص عن بعد دخول عمرو بن العاص
وهو بيخلص من قراءته ان هذا لم يحدث هم
اقروا النشاط وعملوا زي ما حضرتك قلت اذا
كان في خمر مثلا بتحرم اذا كان في بتقن
وفقا ل بس ل لكن جوهر النشاط الاقتصادي لم
يتغير لا والطرح السائد دعني اقول عشان
ننهي الموضوع ده من
جانب الفئات السياسيه التي تطرح شعار
الاسلام والحل هو في الواقع نظام اقرب ما
يكون الى النظام الراس مالي في صيغات
الليبرالي الجديده اللي هي بتطبخ حاليا
وانا بتكلم هنا من منطلق بقى الممارسه
العمليه حينما كنت وزيرا واصطدمت
ب جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وكان وقتها منهم
الرئيس ومنهم اغلبيه ساحقه في مجلس الايه
مجلس الشعب الكلام ده في الفتره
2011 2012
زيه وذلك كان دفاعي رئيس وقتها كان كان
رئيس رئيس جه في 2012 ا 2012 اخر 2012 اه
انا قعدت لغايه الدكتور محمد مرسي مظبوط
لغايه اغسطس 2012
ا ف فعايز اقول انه لا يوجد ما يسمى
الاقتصاد الاسلامي عشان نخلص من القصه دي
وانما يوجد القيم الاسلاميه الايه العليا
فقط لغير فايده البنوك ليست ربا في كل
الاحوال بحيث انها يعني يعني تحرم اعمالا
للنص الايه النص القراني الصيغ البديله
بمسميات شكلا تتوافق
مع الاسلام الاسلام ولكن عمليا هي شديده
الظلم لان تعمل لصالح الاقوى وعلى حساب
تجربتنا في السودان تجربه ثريه جدا يعني
انفقت ثلاث سنين من عمري بدرس هذه التجربه
ودهشت جدا انا كان عندي الانطباعات دي لان
كان عندي اصدقاء في مصر متيمين بالتجربه
السودانيه وكن السودان هيحقق الامن
الغذائي السودان خلى البنود كلها اسلاميه
وانا كنت خالفهم بس انتهزت الفرصه لتاكيد
شكوكي انا اكثر من شاكر معال الدكتور برض
كالعاده يعني اجبت لنا على اسئله وطرحت في
اذهاننا اسئله اخرى وفضول ان احنا نعرف
تجربتك في السودان وتجربه الحكم هناك
واسئله اخرى اشكرك جدا ون زينك اذا سمح
وقتك نستانف الاسئله باذن الله وانا بس
يعني اتمنى ان اخوانا اللي بيشاهدو يكونوا
عجيبين الصوت المره دي ده بقى مسؤوليه
جون شكرا جزيلا شكرا لحضراتكم ونستانس
الحديث مع الدكتور جوده في حلق الاخرى
باذن الله